the coronavirus knows no borders has
it's spreads across our planet but it is
not an equal opportunities killer these
are disease that that thrives on the
social determinants and on the the
weaknesses the poverty and in the poor
health status so why is it that covered
nineteen seems to affect the very
poorest among us most of all so far from
being the great levelers it's
occasionally been described coronavirus
has further exposed inequalities within
societies all too often it's those at
the bottom of the economic ladder who
are suffering the most senior consultant
dr. G intellicus doing his rounds every
patient must be tested for coronavirus
on admission for some weeks now fewer
and fewer suspected cases have been
coming to the hospital in Darmstadt in
western Germany to begin with in the
beginning we saw very mobile people they
were middle-aged to younger patients
students business travelers
holidaymakers or those returning from a
ski trip for example it was indeed an
atypical composition for a lung Station
like ours and over the course of time
it's shifted a bit the patients are now
significantly older again which is
connected to the fact that more and more
nursing homes are affected and what we
also have to point out is that we've
noticed that some are from a certain
social class Hunt's of aizen's are poor
working conditions low wages little
living space all this increases the risk
of infection and there are also other
barriers sometimes the most severe cases
we've seen here on the ward where new
admissions of kovat patients had x-rays
showing almost complete lung failure
these were in patients who could not
communicate their symptoms clearly
because they did not speak the language
that means the hurdle to seek help was
much higher for these
nobody's mentioned one corridor further
along is the kovat isolation ward right
now only one patient is being treated
here when the pandemic was at its peak
though all the beds were occupied the
doctors here had to pool their
experience with the disease to find out
which patients were hit particularly
hard
I noticed material this clearly has
something to do with social status
starting with the work you do whether
you are more exposed whether you
couldn't work from home but instead had
to continue working at the supermarket
checkout or on public transport of
course that applies more to low paid
jobs that was a factor and in addition
there is also the risk of more severe
progression if you have the disease
already studies have also shown that
that is clearly related to a certain
social status coronavirus patients stay
in hospital for a long time they start
to talk and then they tell doctor
gellick how badly they're doing in their
everyday lives poverty makes people ill
and that's also the case with Kovac 19
well on that point we can hear from
Miroku yen who is a professor of
international management at the Wharton
School in Philadelphia he's done
research into the effects of poverty on
pandemics so I asked him why coronavirus
seems to be hitting the poorest in
societies hardest let's begin with the
fact that many of them have to continue
working they don't have the luxury that
I have which is of working from home
they have to continue commuting to their
place of work and also maybe they don't
have a car they have to use public
transportation so they're always more
exposed to the virus itself and then in
some countries like in the United States
they have less access to health care and
they also tend to live with many other
people in their homes so for all of
those reasons they are both more exposed
to the virus and then they are not as
well prepared to cope with some of the
likely health consequences and is there
the further negative impact of that
that it actually exacerbates the
pandemic having a split within a santur
society
absolutely so whenever you have duality
whenever you have this polarization from
a socio-economic point of view then you
see that one half of the population
perhaps can shield itself can protect
itself from something like a pandemic
but the other half cannot but of course
we are all living in the same planet in
the same communities and we cannot
completely isolate ourselves and given
that you know the virus knows no
boundaries and it travels very quickly
from one place to another we really
should be protecting the entire
population not just half of it so that's
why inequality for social kind of an
economic kind really hinders our efforts
at bringing a pandemic such as this
under control
mr. pandemic widening the gap between
rich and poor within societies yes so
most of the let's look at it in the
following way most of the people who
have lost their jobs are people who are
towards the lower end of the
socio-economic scale you know for many
well-paying service sector jobs these
are most of the time highly educated
workers you know those jobs can still be
performed those companies still have
customers they are still having revenue
they can still operate but it is
unfortunately a lot of those workers in
other kinds of industries lower paying
jobs that are being for the most part
affected by unemployment think about
restaurant workers that have been you
know losing their jobs think about other
types of workers for example who have to
attend to facilities that have being
shut down by the crisis so all of those
jobs have disappeared
most of the unemployed are people
towards the lower end of the
socio-economic scale
unfortunately so what can we do to
counteract the
increasing imbalance and making sure
that everyone is brought a little closer
together yes so well obviously the
long-term game here is to try to flatten
the curve try to achieve herd immunity
try to come up with treatments and also
potentially eventually with a vaccine
but in the meantime we need the
government we need companies we need
society to take care of those people so
that they're not left behind because
once again the the negative consequences
of this pandemic are so unequally
distributed that if we do not do
something we're gonna see a huge
increase in terms of poverty and just
more broadly inequality and we've been
talking so far about inequality within
societies but what about between
societies are we likely to see an
increase in the gulf between rich
countries and poor countries well I
think that there are three categories of
countries in the world I mean we have
the least developed parts of the world a
very poor countries we have emerging
markets such as China or India or Turkey
and so on and then we have the richest
countries I mean from the data that I've
seen in terms of forecasts what we see
is that some parts of the advanced
countries are going to recover very
slowly
that's especially Europe unfortunately
and also some of the very poor countries
are going to be very very much heavily
affected but among emerging markets some
of them like Brazil we know is going to
suffer a lot but others pain not as much
so I'd say it's a more complicated
picture than just that the distinction
between rich and poor obviously the rich
have better health care they have better
instruments of their disposal but that
doesn't mean their economies are gonna
recover as fast from these crises and
once again I am particularly concerned
about what may happen in Europe
as Professor Mauro Guillen from the
Wharton School at the University of
Pennsylvania there and now it's your
chance to ask the questions is a science
correspondent tarik Williams
what kinds of antibody tests are being
used antibody tests are used to detect
whether you've been exposed to the virus
and are producing antibodies that could
protect you from future infection there
are a number of approaches for detecting
them but but two are especially
important on the commercial market
the first type is what's called a rapid
diagnostic test or an RD T it's a
point-of-care test that often looks
similar to a pregnancy test and it gives
the same kinds of of colored line
results positive or negative the second
type of test called an Eliza test that's
short for for enzyme-linked
immunosorbent assay it's performed by
professionals in the lab on a larger
blood or plasma sample some it traps
target antibodies on plates that are
coded with proteins from a pathogen and
it makes those antibodies visible eliza
tests are more sophisticated and
accurate but rdt tests are much faster
and cheaper if my partner gets Kovac 19
after me can I give her a plasma
transfusion would that help her what's
known as convalescent plasma therapy has
been around for for about a century it
involves taking blood plasma from people
who have recovered from a disease and
injecting it into someone who is still
sick because the plasma contains
antibodies it can at least theoretically
help the recipient fight off the illness
now we know the method can bring
positive results with other pathogens
and and we're hopeful it'll do the same
with SARS Cove - but trials are still
ongoing on
when and whether and how effective
convalescent plasma therapy is against
kovat 19:00 meanwhile with a lack of
other effective medicines plasma is
being administered in emergency
situations because it's been shown to be
safe and healthcare authorities are
requesting that people who have
recovered donate as often as possible
[Music]